[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حقيقي من لما تواصلوا معاي الاخوه في تد
يعني نبهوني وكرروا علي بان محاضرات تد من
طبيعتها لا تزيد عن 18
دقيقه وانا اليوم احاول تحطيم الرقم
القياسي واخباركم بخمس محاضرات خلال 15
دقيقه يعني لا يغركم الاسم الكبير هنا هذه
المحاضرات يمكن اختصارها تحت عنوان عريض
وهو كي لا نصبح نسخا مكرره من الاخرين كي
لا تصبح انت نسخه مكرره من الناس حولك
نحاول تشجيع التميز الفردي فكما هو معروف
المجتمعات اي مجتمع مكونين من مجموعه
كبيره من الافراد هؤلاء الافراد متشابهون
في العمق متشابهون في في المبادئ في طرق
التفكير في المفاهيم
الاساسيه صحيح اننا يعني لسنا متشابهون
بنسبه 100% ولكننا متشابهون بنسبه ساحقه
لدرجه تميزنا عن المجتمعات الاخرى وهذه
المحاضره الهدف منها هو
تنبيهكم الى حقيقه ان لا تكونوا نسخ مكرره
من بقيه افراد المجتمع ولكن من الناحيه
الايجابيه والناحيه
الحميده محاضرتنا الاولى تتعلق بحقيقه ان
99% من الافكار افكارك الخاصه افكارك التي
تعتقد انها خاصه بك ومستقله وتدافع عنها
بل وتحاول نشرها هي في الحقيقه افكار
ابتكرها اشخاص
غيرك فاكك التي تعتقد انها خاصه بك هي اما
افكار موروثه او افكار منطه او افكار
مسايره للمجتمع او مسايره للمفاهيم
الموجوده في المجتمع
قد يسالني احدكم ومن اين اتيت بالمصدر او
المرجع 99 كثير
99% حقيقي المصدر والمرجع هو انتم انتم
عودوا الى انفسكم واخبروني بفكره واحده
بفكره واحده ابتكرت موها بمفهوم واحد لم
يسبقكم به احد من العالمين حين تفكرون
بالامر بهذه الطريقه تكتشفون ان حتى ال
99% هذه ليست مبالغا فيها حتى 90% هذه
ليست مبالغا فيها بالعكس حتى العباقر
الكبار حتى العباقر الكبار لم ينشئوا
اشياء من العدم بل بداوا من اخر سلمه او
اخر درجه انتهى فيها العباقر الذين سبقوهم
يقول نيوتن على سبيل المثال ان كنت رايت
اكثر من غيري فلاني وقفت على اكتاف
العظماء الهدف من هذه المحاضره هو ان
انبهكم فقط الى هذه الاليه كي لا تكونوا
نسخه مكرره من الناس حولكم تنبهوا لهذه
الاليه حاولوا بمرور الزمن ان ترفعوا من
نسبه افكاركم الخاصه والمستقله وفي نفس
الوقت تراجعوا وتنظر بعين النقد والمراجعه
للافكار التي اقتسب سموها من الغير هذه
محاضرتنا
الاولى محاضرتنا الثانيه على فكره هذه
الصوره لي في احدى القرى الفلبينيه
النائيه وهنا مجموعه من الاطفال يرون
صورهم لاول مره في الكاميرا
مستغربين طيب محاضرتنا الثانيه تتعلق
بالاطفال الابطال بطبيعتهم
عباقره الطفل بطبيعته عبقري يملك اهم صفه
في العبقريه وهي الدهشه وكثره التساؤل وحب
المعرفه والاستطلاع الطفل يطرح يوميا ما
بين 100 الى 400 سؤال كيف ولماذا ومتى
واين وليش لانه يولد مثل سبوره بيضاء صفحه
فارغه مثل كمبيوتر لم يحمل بعد باي برنامج
يحاول انشاء برنامجه المعرفي الخاص فيطرح
الكثير الكثير الكثير من الاسئله يطرح
اسئله لدرجه ان نحنا الكبار ما نقدر نجاوب
عليها او ببساطه نقول له اسكت خلاص يكفي
ولكن الحقيقه اننا نحن الكبار عقولنا
اصيبت
بالصدا سلمناها للمسلمات والبديهيات فاصبح
كل اللي حوالينا بديه ومسلم لماذا نتساءل
حوله لو عودون لعائلاتكم تتذكرون اطفالا
كان يسال اسئله غريبه انا اتذكر ابن حسام
هو صغير سالني اسئله غريبه كنت محتار فيها
كان يسالني يا بابا ليش لون السما
ازر بابا ليش ليش الرجال عندهم
شنبات ليش ما يغرق
السمك هل تستطيع انتم تجيبوا على هذه
الاسئله
لا لو لو لو انكم قررتم فعلا ان تجيبوا عن
مثل هذه الاسئله الطفوليه البريئه لربما
اكتشفتهم يعني نظريات عجيبه مثلا في علم
الاحياء في علم المناخ في علم البحار
العباقره هم الفئه الوحيده من البشر التي
كبرت ولكنها لم تفقد دهشه الطفوله حين
تراجع تاريخ الاكتشافات العلميه
والاختراعات تجدوها انها ظهرت بعد سؤالا
طفوليا بريئا لانك حين تطرح سؤال طفولي
بريء تخرج بنتيجه استثنائيه وغير مسبوقه
على سبيل المثال الاخوه مجلوف اخترعوا
منطاد الهواء ساخن بعد ان تساءل احدهما
لماذا الدخان يصعد الى الاعلى في احد عمره
سال نفسه هذا
السؤال عندنا اديسون ابتكر المصباح
الكهربائي لانه لاحظ ان السلك الكهربائي
حين تمر به الكهرباء يبدا بالتوهج فابتكر
المصباح الكهربائي نيوتن اكتشف قانون
الجاذبيه والقوانين التي اتت من بعده بعد
ماذا بعدما تساءل لماذا سقطت التفاحه من
الشجره يا جماعه التفاح يتساقط من ملايين
السنين ولو سقط التفاحه بقربي او بقربك
كنا
اكلناها ولكنه تساءل و بهذه الطريقه توصل
الى قانون الجاذبيه لهذا السبب وكي لا
تكونوا نسخه مكرره من بقيه الناس حولكم
احتفظوا بدهشه الطفوله لا تتحرج من طرح
الاسئله الطفوليه البريئه والساذج بالعكس
حين تطرح سؤالا طفوليا ساذجا تخرج بنتيجه
استثنائيه وغير مسبوقه هذه الان رتنا
الثانيه محاضرتنا الثالثه عن الفرق بين
السؤال والتساؤل انا متاكد ان في ناس كثير
عمرهم ما سالوا نفسهم ايش الفرق بين
السؤال والتساؤل انا شخصيا ما كنت
اعرف ولكن قررت ان اكتب مقالا في هذا
الامر فبديت ابحث ايش الفرق بين السؤال
والتساؤل السؤال تطرحه كي تحصل على اجابه
جاهزه اجابه جاهزه من
الاخرين اما التساؤل فحاله تساؤل داخلي في
نفسك عميقه تطرحها بينك وبين نفسك السؤال
في الغالب يكون سريعا وتاتيك الاجابه اسرع
اما التساؤل فقد ياخذ منك عمرا طويلا وقد
تموت ولم تجب على هذا
التساؤل السؤال بطبيعه الحال ليس عيبا لا
تفهموني غلط السؤال ليس عيبا بل هو مفتاح
العلم بل هو مفتاح العلم ولكن العيب كل
العيب هو ان تسال الناس وبشكل دائم وحتى
حين تكبر وتصبح في نهايه العمر تسال الناس
ارائهم فالناس حين يمنحوك اجوبته يمنحوك
اجوبه
مشوهه اجوبه تختلط بافكارهم الخاصه
بمواقفهم الخاصه بتحيز بميلا تهم بتاثير
بيئتهم الخاصه اما التساؤل فينبع من داخلك
اجابه نقيه طاهره غير متاثره باي تحيز
تكون مقتنعا فيها اكثر مما لو اتاك الجواب
جاهزا لهذا السبب وكي لا تكون نسخه مكر من
الناس الموجودين حولكم ارفعوا من نسبه
تساؤلاتكم العميقه وخفضوا قليلا من نسبه
الاسئله فال الاسئله ان كانت خاصه بطلاب
العلم فان التساؤل هو من طبيعه الفلاسفه
والمفكرين الكبار هم الذين تسائلون بشكل
دائم هذه ايها الساده محاضرتنا
الثالثه محاضرتنا الرابعه كيف يتم تقييد
عقلك يعني للاسف عقولنا تقيد ونحن ايضا
بطريقه خاطئه الاسباب كثيره فنحن نفكر
الطريقه خاطئه بسبب ارائنا المسبقه بسبب
تحيزات بسبب ميولنا الثقافيه بسبب
مفاهيمنا الخاطئه بسبب تاثرنا بالمجتمع
حولنا ولكن
ايضا ما يؤثر على عقولنا هناك اليتين
مهمتين تؤثر على عقولنا الاليه الاولى هي
الاسبقيه الاسبقيه من ناحيه الزمان ماذا
نقصد
بالاسبقيه الاسبقيه الفك الره التي تسبق
الى دماغك تبقى فيه الى الابد صعب تخرج
لهذا السبب احنا ذكرنا الاطفال يولدون
بعقل ابيض بسبوره بيضاء صفحه بيضاء نقيه
فحين تسبق اليه فكره او معتقد او راي تظل
فيه الى الابد صعب صعب تزيحه بعد كده لهذا
السبب في جميع المجتمعات انا لا اتحدث عن
مجتمعنا في جميع المجتمعات قله قليله جدا
من الناس من يغيرون اديانهم ومعتقداتهم
لماذا لانه دائما الاسبق الى ذهنه هو اراء
الوالدين فحين تاتي الفكره صعب ان تزاح
ولا تستقبل شيئا من بعدها ساضرب لكم مثلا
بسيطا مثلا يوميا لو اتاك صديقك واخبرك
قال انا شاهدت حريق في سوق شعبي وهب ضحيته
40 محل
تجاري بعد ساعه اتاك صديق لك وقال انا
رايت حريق في سوق شعبي وذهب ضحيته 60 محل
تجاري قبل ما تداركوا وسائل الدفاع المدني
ستقول له لا لا معلش 40 بس لا يا حبيبي 60
لا لا لا لا 40 طيب ايش اللي خلاك تاخذ ال
40 ما تاخذ ال
60 الامر ببساطه هو ان ال 40 هو الرقم
الذي سبق الى عقلك فانت تشربت واستوطن في
عقلك واصبحت بالعكس تدافع عنه قد يكون ال
60 هو الرقم
الصحيح هذا هو تاثير
الاسبقيه هناك ايضا الاسبقيه من الناحيه
الزمنيه هناك ايضا شغله من الناحيه
المكانيه يعني نحن نساير المجموعه
الموجوده حولنا فانت قد تختلف مع صديقك قد
تختلف مع شخص في راي قد تختلف مع شخصان
حين يكونون ثلاثه ضدك قد تتردد حين يكونون
اربعه في الغالب ستسلم لهم ستكبر جوابك
الخاص وتسلم لهم لانك انت ايضا لا تود ان
تكون خارج السياق الاجتماعي هناك ضريبه ان
خالفت الراي ستكون شاذا و خارج عن السياق
الاجتماعي انا اعتقد ان الاربعه هذ هو
الرقم السحري الرقم السحري الذي من بعده
نسلم عقولنا للناس المتواجدين
حولنا خطر في بالي هذا الرقم اربعه بعد ما
شاهدت مقلبا طريفا في برنامج الكاميرا
الخفيه كان هناك شخص يقف امام المصعد وحين
يضغط الزر يفتح المصعد فيفاج بوجود اربع
اشخاص يقفون بشكل غريب يقفون بهذا
الشكل ضحك في البدايه ثم د دد ولكنه على
اي حال دخل وفعل زيهم كرروا هذه التجربه
بوجود شخص واحد في المصعد فلم يفعل مثله
بالعكس يعني سخر منه شخصين لم يفعل مثلهم
سخر منه ثلاثه البعض تردد والبعض فعل
مثلهم ولكن حين يكونون اربعه الجميع يفعل
هكذا لعله يقول لنفسه ربما هذه من اجراءات
السلامه الجديده او لهذا سب وهذه ظاهره
هذه مهمه يعني كثير من الاشخاص حتى حين
تتامل كثير من الاشخاص الذين ينضمون على
سبيل المثال للمنظمات الارهابيه قد حين
يذهب سيفعل مثلهم ويفعل كل ما يفعلون
لماذا لانه صعب عليه في ذلك الوقت ان يخرج
عن اطار الجماعه س سيصبح
منبوذا فلهذا السبب ان اردتم ان تكونون
مميزين عن غيركم وكي لا تكونوا نسخه مكرره
من بقيه الناس حولكم تنبهوا لهاتين
الاليتين
الاسبقيه وتاثير الاربعه حوالينا اربعه
وار ملايين ما تفرق
طيب محاضرتنا الخامسه انا عندي محاضره
سابقه بعنوان اهم عش صفات في العباقره او
اهم عش صفات في الابداع كان هذه هي اهم
قاعده اهم قاعده في الابداع هي كسر جميع
القواعد السابقه الابداع حين تتامل فيه
حتى من الناحيه اللغويه تكتشف ان الابداع
هو الخروج بشيء جديد وشيء غير مستطرق من
قبل وشيء غير معروف وشيء لم يسبقك به احد
من الناس كيف تفعل ذلك وانت ما زلت تتقيد
بالقوالب القديمه بالقواعد القديمه
بالافكار القديمه التي يعرفها جميع الناس
ان اردت ان تكون مبدعا ومميزا عند حد معين
يجب ان تترك جميع القواعد السابقه وتبدا
بانشاء البناء من
جديد هذه القاعده تفيدكم ايا كان تخصصكم
في مجال الطب في مجال الفقه في مجال الادب
في مجال الهندسه ايا كان التخصص اهم قاعده
في الابداع هي ان تكسر جميع القواعد
السابقه على سبيل المثال خلينا ناخذ مثال
من الهندسه المعماريه جميع الناسين حت حت
في الدول الخارجيه في اي مكان في العالم
يبنون منازلهم بشكل صندوقي مربع مكعبات من
الاسمنت قد يصرف عليها البعض الملايين وقد
نجملها بالرخام والسيراميك الى اخره
ولكنها في النهايه مكعبات
اسمنتيه طيب لو واحد جا مثلا قال انا لا
اكسر جميع القواعد السابقه وا اسوي شي
مختلف سبني منزلي مثل قارب شراعي على سبيل
المثال كصفه كزهره اللوتس كزجاج عطر في
ذلك الوقت سنمر من امام هذا المنزل ونقول
هذا الرجل مبدع ولكن الحقيقه هذا الرجل
ليس اذكى مني ومنك هذا الرجل فقط كانت
عنده اراده اراده كسر جميع القواعد
السابقه القواعد وكسرها هناك شرط يجب ان
يتم كي تحقق نتيجه ايجابيه نتيجه حميده
هذه ا الساده محاضرات الخمس خلال 15
دقيقه بس لم انتهي بعد طيب الان ما هو
الرابط بين كل هذه المحاضرات الخمس الرابط
هو انت عزيزي انت انت من يجب ان يرفع من
نسبه اسئلته الخاصه ويخفض من نسبه تاثير
المجتمع عليها 99% انت من يجب ان يميز بين
السؤال والتساؤل ويطرح تساؤلاته العميقه
انت من لا يجب ان يقيد عقله او يؤجره
للاسبق او لتاثير الناس من حوله انت من
يجب ان يكسر جميع القواعد السابقه ان اراد
بالفعل ان يبدع في اي مجال يتصوره وان كان
هناك من شريحه اخيره فهي يعني يكفي نسخ
مكرره ايها الساده والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[تصفيق]
وبركاته